what's up it's your boy super gamer 5
welcome last episode I beat the hardest
level with Verrill death in case you're
not familiar with me my name is Pierre
I have never died in a video game ever
in my life so I beat the hardest level
and you guys weren't impressed
apparently there's a DLC in crash
bandicoot over of a map that was deleted
from the game because the level was too
hard well the game was too hard and it's
too racked up shop
stormy SN more like for me that's why
got them all here we go oh it's just
like that it's just the hardest level
ever
apparently currently the developer was
like oh I didn't really know how to make
the difficulty not spike okay wow this
is so hard
this is practically impossible oh my god
he's throwing toxic
this is virtually impossible Wow
what does it do incredible this is just
like just oh my god how fast do I got to
be Jesus oh I got to time my jumps now
as to [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you zero
deaths by the way thank you
oh wow that was SuperDuper difficult you
guys are right all along
hardest level ever mud yeah it's the
hardest level ever when did this game
get hard I don't get it I genuinely
don't get it
I think you're all a bunch of crybaby
[ __ ] who needs to suck on your mama's
pet it here we go Crash Bandicoot what I
wasn't even near a whatever zero depth
that does not count obviously does not
count
no you [ __ ] [ __ ] really why do I have
to [ __ ] redo everything if I fall
down [ __ ] you
Jesus Christ I thread the only reason
they deleted this was because it's too
easy as to as act [ __ ] you didn't even
hit me easy
just kidding was easy what the hell is
give me that check point by give it our
chick bone boy the [ __ ] is that what
does that thing I [ __ ] it there right in
my ez barrel death thanks that's [ __ ]
easy
oh my god
so yeah man look at this [ __ ] I got
skills for days son
[ __ ] you bird don't touch me old man
been dodging old men from touching me
all my life shoutout to my uncle I'm
joking
he wanted my sister I'm joking come here
bird give you back massage bird don't
molest me mane and that's [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] whenever I pick some yeah blah this
lamp is so [ __ ] hot I'm so sick of
these lamps got nothing to do what's
happening in the game the goddamn I'm
tired of this [ __ ] lamp being so
goddamn [ __ ] high Jesus Christ I'm a
lamp I'm gonna be super hot - shut up
pig [ __ ] watch me beat this level blind
girl legit I could be playing this with
my ass and so beat it of course oh yeah
look at that [ __ ] boy
II the game so nerf earth crash too
strong they [ __ ] fight computer [ __ ]
easy as Abidjan yeah that's it my man my
man man you want back massage man yeah
you go man hi welcome
I don't even wait for the chair because
it's too easy
I don't need bears in the game oh Jesus
all right don't touch me old man what
did I say about all men touching them me
okay
Oh a little too early that's okay yeah
[ __ ] damn it that's okay that's okay
it must have been a mistake somewhere
look at this [ __ ] boy but a little bit
of a dad
come on main get me a challenge man [ __ ]
y'all man I wonder which one of you
whiny sons of [ __ ] is like oh this
game is metal it's too hard we must
delete it from the game otherwise I will
talk [ __ ] you [ __ ] you what the [ __ ] was
that
come in boy come here son boom it's not
even funny
okay okay whatever I'm [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I was actually born inside this video
game not a lot of people know about it
it's a legend about [ __ ] look at this
[ __ ] son
Oh God believe again look at this ship
boy ha respect Rick [ __ ] you why would
you come where I am
easiest stupidest jump derivative
respect respect respect respect respect
respect respect Jesus Christ respect
respect respect respect respect
management or respect monomer Mahna
Mahna Mahna Mahna can you [ __ ] [ __ ]
stop - stop here it is
here ready okay okay let me look at the
pattern let me study the pattern just
look dog so you got to learn to move sex
okay flip that was so easy because I'm
so good at games Dark Souls specifically
oh my god come out
[ __ ] what did they send hmm okay what
good timing look at the timing hmm [ __ ]
off
where am I where's my [ __ ] checkpoint
where's my [ __ ] checkpoint my name is
Jeff [ __ ] where's my [ __ ] Jeff won
where's my [ __ ] checkpoint where's my
[ __ ] checkpoint
hmm not today I met the spiky boy yeah
just point give it to me give it to me
boy Oh respect the women oh it's gonna
be tough fun fun hell oh my god
[ __ ] off man
gee thanks give me a life [ __ ] you piece
of [ __ ] [ __ ] go [ __ ] you don't [ __ ]
yourself
piece of [ __ ] ass